you're what is up guys pastiche you
today and what is this what is this what
is this what is this we got the hair
over an experienced guys what is up back
with the hair of an experience you guys
might notice uh there's no Little Harbor
next to me that is because of the Mahdi
and stuffs hard minecraft my old mods
for mac and so I got needy yeah it's
it's complicated don't he'll be back in
one of you upcoming episodes so hello
guys i finally got the hair brand
experience over on my pc and now we'd be
rolling in dough so slightly out of the
bed yeah that made no sense i apologize
but i finally got my urban experience
the save files over here so this series
will be continuing as of today and if
you saw my intro than that means you're
gonna see my outro I don't know if those
that simple work since I didn't make
that on a Mac as well and we'll see
though if you're new to the series hello
i am prestige and another proving oh my
god but uh this is the basically this is
my survival series i do with that it's
kind of been an assortment of urban mods
but just something through hair band
hence the name the herbert experience
and try to keep to my best to that and
yeah so it's continuing with the
adventure I've done this kinda a few
times hopefully my recording system
fraps route on me they've dealt with me
before and I started getting like weird
bursts of lag and yeah hopefully that
doesn't happen so yeah I've just been
continuing to explore this mine shaft
and
and yet you want pretty good with lapis
nice just blocking this water supply but
see I must have been minded hard cuz i
got two sacks of iron with me so I've
made some space for another sack barn so
I want on the good stuff I have any yeah
abbs labs magnet or deepika already have
stuck lapis okay well we won't be making
any more space for thats cuz I lapis is
use this as my useless but i don't i'm
not planning doing many die things so
yep i'm not gonna be a lot of using
forward lapis home order should i pick
up these mine mine rails i know i can
just make out of iron since i got all
over two stacks pro dang doing work so
yeah hello everybody just this is i I've
been kind of have a weird schedule
recently and I hope even those schools
right now i hope that i can get a more
systematic schedule so you guys will
know what I'm uploading and when it is
urban experience i'm probably gonna do
maybe two to three videos a week I
probably gets try and get a set thing
like every let's say woh bhi cadiz
Tuesday Thursday Saturday something of
you storm and don't hold me to that
exact schedule but it'll be something of
the like so we'll be all good and yet be
all pretty and you just break yeah and
I'm licky and like yeah yeah so I'm just
not as cold oh cool so that zombies now
an Endermen I'm not gonna try fighting
him just because I don't I do not want
to risk dying I'm just gonna go the
other way so I've 33 experience points I
should like try oh hello I should really
try getting back to my house cuz uh
like I have 30 experience I have
multiple diamonds i have two over two
stacks of iron I got all the goods on me
bro all the goods it's over here hmm Oh
it kind of sounds like the zombies all
right now we're to do I'm just like
walking everywhere bro I just want to
explore the mine shaft and I want to
like get the goods and then over here oh
no do not it's it I sorry guys this the
Norton thing just show k sorry guys in
Norton thing just popped out of nowhere
and I'm like bro what you want he's like
I want to secure your stuff so I'm like
oh that's actually pretty good so I'm
just going to minimize human deal with
you later x i'm recording a video at the
moment and you can't be interrupting
that man so so don't worry guys I talked
him talking down they won't be he
shouldn't be bothering us for the rest
of the video gold bro so I heard they
changed the in the new update they
changed the recipe for goal for gold
apples like I for gold apples right now
I made that with like three to four
golden gets since you can make it with
gold nuggets just surrounding it but i
was told that they uh like gonna have
any space for coal i was told that
they're switching it up no I don't want
cobblestone I was told to switching up
and now you need ingots to make the
poopy golden apples and like my n not
even that good so now though recipe for
smaller golden apples is ingot and the
look more legit cool apples is blocks as
it was before so that didn't change but
uh the others have changed and that
sucks because now i will be able to like
mass-produce golden apples look give me
all your calls son i want coal to power
the furnaces into the dark ages even
though that was in that pass rush no one
needs to know that do to do to do more
iron because i need I
another want to no no no no I'm like get
the pic x okay its acts no sword no axe
no sore no gosh either those are used
for mine in come on you should know this
game get out of my way grapple it's not
your house on this already explored area
I think it is but just to help myself
out I'm gonna block this okay yeah this
was when i did my parkour jumps I just
jump to the right okay more iron song
I'm probably going to start making my
way back homes in mattoon it's like I
just can't just kind of hold this bro no
one of the tips I already got a third oh
dang bro i really don't need an ender
pearl since i'm gonna have that other
little hairpin dude channel with me and
he can he can teleport so and he takes
away less hearts in a ender pearl so
that's the joy I'll gave me this cold
bro you know what this cool you don't
want that black good stuff oh and is
that finding another place nice nice
already okay I guess I'll pick up like a
stack of rail since i already have an
inventory space a lot for it whoo-hoo
and one more who alright so let's let's
make my way up oh I can have to break
that so start a good broke my torch
towards I'll just place down email this
the call is cold calls just like
whatever bro I like a low noise uh nope
nothing over there alright so let's take
some as coal no let's take some us would
no not like that like this and then take
this and you like that and then take
this and put that there and put that
there and boom stack torches but
Sammer's Tristar saying that Sammer's no
doing that that'd be weird Oh more irons
on I'm get this on I really have no idea
when I started this video so we'll just
I go to a feel like ending does a good
plan i think it's good plan alright
mfers from every parkour parkour parkour
ok perk or weep record that up son i
would really like to find some more
chests picking up all these a slime just
slime chunk or little slimy little slimy
oh gosh what the nose I wanted to be
with the Sun now you made me can't slime
notice love go to set in order we've
lost a friend the slime to bed he will
be missed forever I think I started this
because I wanted like find dungeons
because I I wanted to want to find like
name tags and stuff so I could get a
horse or like just name any animal and
being my world forever but I've not
found or maybe I have found the dungeon
and I just there was no good smart lots
of hello coming i'm just gonna kitty now
since i already arty I'm already slidin
murderer so as well might as well go out
kill them all as well be a good sly
murderer we don't need Flint's hopefully
I used it to use to make arrows but we
have lots of gravel so we can just just
mind that repeatedly to get the goods so
this just breaks off into caverns I'm
gonna take you i'm gonna take this cabin
down so goodbye my shaft was nice
knowing you can use iron cuz on yeah
you-you-you spoons so I'm prescribed
more iron than I do Cole at the moment
like in my inventory so I don't think
that supposed to be at like it is it was
Ritter we just pick up some that all
right let's go fight the spider do I
have yet i have another sack know what
else and see underneath and she'll give
me the cold no no no no cops go on their
cups down that I am go over the iron son
get that iron hey you gotta get it I'm
making I'm trying to go down because I
want to I want to get some diamonds oh I
smell eats yeah she definitely needs eat
the noms who's that gold sign of that
gold you're hooked me up some of that
hook me up some of that grew and we're
just getting all the minerals minerals
okay okay okay drop drop drop out hello
kind sir Oh creeps I see the Cooper's
over there two are legit you guys off in
one shot on bro I missed and then you
should be dead okay you did oh oh gosh
torch torch torch torch oh dang berlocq
Alyssa torch let's figure this iron
let's go in search of data Mullins is
going to be to some dangerous stuff
going in this lava infested areas ah bad
gosh Oh out of felt man oh no changers
why are there so many zombies let me
just put this here I should deal with
the lever awesome take some of this let
me just put a try tending to put a torch
gets better than nothing let's go
zombies got nothing to this I'm sore bro
I get us awesome lapis but who cares
about nap is yeah I didn't see let's see
some lapis I was getting high is place
you know oh I don't know know know know
that
let that go there we go okay nothing
over there drop some iron I voice crack
when I see you yeah masculinity good
okay break you I really need the auto
switch mom that is what I need I know
tom is bro all right well I think it is
time to start making our way back up top
so I'm going to make to the surface than
I might call it Oh buddy or like I'll
see where I am in accordance with the
red Sun are backwards sorry I just kind
of got a little bit sidetracked okay i
just wanna just want to explore
everything yeah man store everything so
much iron man like is there anything
like I'm just going to just like make 50
iron golems think that's what's going to
end up adding hate pumpkins for that
though pumpkins 222222 to gold I want
that picking their goods i'll call it
gold oh gosh so much gold there's a lot
of gold actually dang jump up here whoa
lag like my stuff oz in mini zombie you
know what I'm just gonna get up fraps
okay okay hope is drop down to 30 frames
so fraps is like a deep pool telling me
how many zombie whatever let's go do 22
22 oh gosh that is scary noises ones
like just so I don't get ambushed by the
creeps haha I can't get up all right
let's continue to loom continue
did you tell me oh hello I have reached
some thing bro bro bro bro you cereal
bro bro all right so uh let's see we
found ourselves a dungeon okay so uh it
looks like to be a spider dungeon the
most annoying kind of Dungeon actually
skeletons may be more annoying let's
build myself a staircase and like let's
shoot these guys shoot you shoot you and
ok it's but it's building more go go go
go go go uh oh hello yeah yeah let's go
let's go oh gosh I've no I'm not gonna
gentle oh how those noobs those boobs
get rekt up it's a good place I chose to
go up where I did ok flame once my
string gunpowder bread wheat bread and
I'm 10 hello ok sir that's you all right
i think i'll take the punch 14 uh
actually one second second no you know
i'm just going to throw that take the
flame one and let's pick up a little
more this mossy cobblestone since most
kelp stone is always very nice very nice
to use and i'm at 55 so i'll be able to
stack soon let's get a stack all day oh
gosh once i get a stack for go back up
ok we have a stack who stopped right in
a sack i can boss let's continue going
up over it this way hoorah son this
music is not going with my ride oh come
on music step up your game and one more
piece of gravel to block them all you
stay i blocked off ok go what am I at f3
wise woman I'm kind of close like this
is probably just gonna be oh gosh I was
like this probably gonna be like just a
pocket of sand and it's like yeah no
that was I mean I pocket of dirt and
like nope that was the full thing why am
I getting like what the heck i can't go
to this hand
yeah what what what happened oh gosh
okay do that okay the San did break i
was just Magnus all right I guess we hit
a lake or the ocean and we feel to make
that I'm precious the ocean he or lake
I'm go with lake lake Oh what it's right
next to male college it bruh that's that
is a beautiful ending oh gosh lux I'll
see where my house is no my house is
right there son oh gosh you see the
giant smiley face yeah I'll just take
this just to take it oh I'm not gonna
leave it up oh whoa oh gosh lag oh gosh
alright guys so I'm getting some
performance alerts so I think this oh
whoa okay lag is going crazy alright
guys I'm just gonna look to the sky hope
you all enjoyed this video if you did
make sure you leave a like rate comment
or subscribe ma'am my piece is just off
the walls just like jumping from like 10
to 90 I hope you enjoyed if you did make
sure you'll agree comment or subscribe
and I'll see you later peace out
ha
you